Emily:
Sometimes when I write,
I lose control.
♪♪
Only you would show up at a
party...
...looking like a raccoon.
I'm not here for the party.
Come on, I need to know-
-Emily...
What did you think of my poems?
Tell me!
I loved them.
♪♪
Sue:
I always love your poems,
but I can't be your only reader
anymore.
You need to share your writing
with the world.
♪♪
Sue: There's someone that I need
you to meet.
♪♪
Sue:
Sam Bowles.
Sue: This could be the man to
put you in the spotlight.
♪♪
I'm always interested in hearing
a new voice.
♪♪
Emily:
What if I don't want...
...fame?
How do you want to be
remembered?
♪♪
I'm thrilled that I could bring
the two of you together.
Emily:
Feels like...
♪♪
Emily:
...destiny.
It is so crazy...
...Sue is an influencer.
♪♪
I don't want to disappear from
this Earth...
...without anybody knowing who I
am.
♪♪
Does anybody else have any
intentions?
The witches of Salem walked so
we could run.
(Lightning crashes)
(Gasping)
♪♪
Emily:
Sometimes when I write...
...I lose control.
♪♪
You're about to become world
famous overnight.
♪♪
Your aura is negative right now.
Emily: I used to have this
confidence...
Emily:
...but not since I met him.
What a crazy day this is.
Not as crazy as what's going on
up here.
She's so extra.
♪♪
Emily: If you could put your
name on what you wrote,
♪♪
would you?
Who wouldn't?
♪♪
This is the opportunity of a
lifetime.
Emily:
You pressured me into this.
I don't even recognize you!
♪♪
Nobody: I think it's kinda like...
Nobody:  ...Death.
What's up, girl?
♪♪
Emily: Part of me is pretty sure
that fame isn't good for me.
♪♪
Emily: In fact, I think it could
be very dangerous.
♪♪ Welcome to the dark side ♪♪
♪♪
Whoa!
-What?
It's like your brain is on fire.
Oh, that tracks.
♪♪